it's great to welcome to the program
Janki ogre who is of course known to
many in our audience as the longtime
host of The Young Turks also
congressional candidates seeking to
represent California's 25th district
Jenkins so great to talk to you David
so there's so much to discuss but I'm
gonna first let's just assume my
audience does not know your platform I
know many of them do but let's start
there issue-oriented
what is it from a policy perspective
that you want to bring to the House of
Representatives yeah so the main reason
I'm running is because I got tired of
people not talking about the corruption
so some folks are now beginning to touch
on it they're using that word but
they're not explaining to people what
the heart of the problem is and how to
fix it so the reality is actually almost
every American including almost every
Republican voter let alone Democratic
voter knows that if ExxonMobil is giving
a politician money that's a bribe
now the Supreme Court legalized those
bribes sue Citizens United in other
decisions but their bribes nonetheless
nobody thinks that they're giving it for
charity
but yet not only will the Republicans
say no no they are they just happen to
agree with ExxonMobil right but eighty
percent of the Democratic Party agrees
to that same fiction and the corporate
media also agrees that same fiction is
it an amazing then they're right
thousands upon thousands of articles
about politics and never talk about the
actual cause of the legislations the
electoral victories the heart of what
actually politics is money is about 90%
of what you should talk about in
politics because that's what determines
the elections but the media never talks
about it it really is stunning so I'm
here to point out the bribery and run a
clean campaign but then that has effect
on every other issue so let's say you
look at Medicare for all my opponent for
example is taking money from insurance
companies so I obviously I'm running
corporate PAC free no lobbyist money etc
so I don't know if it's a real opinion
that everybody in the country shouldn't
have
scare I don't know if it's a real
opinion the private insurance system
should be maintained Orbitz that way
because she got paid for that opinion me
on the other hand whether you like my
policy stances or not you know at least
there's no question that I'm honest and
it's my real opinions we need Medicare
for all in this country 45,000 people a
year die because they don't have health
insurance that's unconscionable
I mean imagine a 45,000 people a year
died because they didn't have private
fire insurance and we just let them burn
to death and then a presidential
candidate comes out and says fire
insurance for those who want it no no
Medicare for all Green New Deal and the
school shootings you name it the and
David one more thing and we can talk
about every one of those issues and a
lot more is that it's not just that I'm
more progressive it's that there's no
fight in the Democrats in the corporate
Democrats once they take the corporate
money they unilaterally disarm on their
top issue but again it affects every
other issue so then they just don't
fight the Republicans I mean we I think
almost all the Democrats now have
stopped taking NRA money and they all
agree that we should have federal
background checks at a bare minimum
right but they never fight McConnell
they never point out that he takes
bribes from the NRA and so even though
97% of Americans agree with us on
federal background checks the Democrats
are so weakened and competent that they
can't force the Republicans to vote and
lose on an issue where 97% of Americans
agree with them yeah there's this idea
that you either there's like a false
dichotomy that exists when analyzing
candidacies like yours and others which
is oh he or she is only focusing on
stuff they disagree with Democrats on
and it's like well hold on a second we
know where the Republicans are on a lot
of these issues isn't it more relevant
to separate yourself from what some
other Democrat would do since that's
increasingly the question I find it to
be a false choice between they should
only be focusing on what Republicans do
wrong was that what we know what the
Republicans doing wrong it's important
to know where they'd be different from
what other Democrats would do as well
that seems to be missed
from the analysis hundred-percent look
it's like when right-wingers say
shouldn't you be focusing on what
al-qaeda does wrong but guys we all know
that al-qaeda is a hundred percent wrong
and we can't influence that at all we
can fight them militarily but it's not
like we could convince al-qaeda to go in
the right direction it's already way too
late for them so it's saying like oh you
know you should be telling people
Republicans are wrong but it's not like
Mitch McConnell's gonna be like oh man I
saw Young Turks and David Pakman show
that give me good points like they just
that is a at best of fundamental naivete
about how politics works so the last six
seven days I have even been surprised
about the degree to which number one
this race is being discussed at this
early stage
I mean it's notable you could say it's
good that your race is being discussed
so much at this early stage however when
you look at what is being discussed it
is a lot of attacks on you coming from a
lot of different people and we have seen
establishment legacy media go after you
we have seen attacks from within the
Democratic Party start to come after you
and I don't even know how to start the
conversation because it seems like
there's really two conversations here to
be had one is the establishment versus
outsider thing that you've already sort
of alluded to there is another
conversation which I think is the more
difficult one to have sometimes within
the left which is the purity test stuff
that sometimes can get a little bit
toxic and this all seems to relate to
some blog posts you wrote years ago
which you've already copped to and said
I said the wrong thing I don't stand by
the stuff so on and so forth and the
sort of recycling of that into what
seems to me to be a moral argument that
is trying to be made against you
including by people who don't even
really know who you are is what I've
noticed is that how you would summarize
it first of all yeah David that's a
great summary I would actually add one
other
so let me break it down so first there's
the corporate Democrats and they are
completely disingenuous
so they attacked me from day one they
know that they don't like because I'm
too progressive in their minds right but
they disingenuously attack me as if I
was not progressive enough now they
don't believe that for a second and they
all released the same talking points on
the same day so it was and it was the
first day of my camera so it was clear
that it was top-down somebody in
California politics and the Democratic
Party said go get this guy and because
it wasn't just my opponents campaign it
was every one of these little local
State County groups etc with the same
exact talking points verbatim none of
them ever asked me hey why do 50 million
progressives watch you every month
that's curious I mean if you were really
are this guy from the blogs from 19
years ago
why do progressives like you what I mean
if I was them at a bare minimum if you
were anywhere near honest you would you
would have intellectual curiosity well
this is strange right but no none of
them reached out they don't want to
reach out reach out to one group leader
and he said I will never talk to you
okay way to be a Democrat okay
my guess is after I become a congressman
they'll come want to talk to so anyway
so those guys are hacks and operatives
and it's clear and I as FDR famously
said I welcome their hatred okay cuz
they keep saying and Christie keeps
saying my opponent I was handpicked by
who and people during an election there
are no voters in that backroom deal I
don't know what the backroom deal was I
certainly wasn't in the backroom no the
voters were in the backroom and by the
way huge fortunes of the district we're
not in the backroom it's a really
insular crowd that makes these this
decisions for the voters sad day for
them we're interrupting that jank 20/20
calm okay they didn't see this coming by
the way so for over 22,000 individual
donations we scared the living hell out
of them the reason they're being so
aggressive is because they
no idea what kind of challenge we could
mount to them there you psych up
progressives please we have the money
you don't have the money they're used to
dismissing us they can't do that with my
campaign and they're reeling so that's
one groups the other group is the
corporate media and I'm actually even
African covered them for all this some
time and having done a critique of them
and saying they have groupthink they're
in a bubble etc I was actually surprised
that it went further than that they were
outright malicious they wrote things
that were not remotely true and they
seem to have done on purpose yeah so let
me bring up one just so the audience
know so there's this New York Times
thing you've you've interviewed David
Duke in the past and like you I've
interviewed lots of extremists and
anybody who understands how these
interviews goes understands that you
don't fight every point to the death
because at a certain point you wouldn't
be able to get fat past the first
question right I mean like we we're
trying to understand where the extremism
comes from and see the internal logic
and in a way that you know what why I
tweeted this example when I interviewed
Richard Spencer once I pointed out he
once dated Asian women it seems to go
against his white supremacy he
eventually said he doesn't do that
anymore
and I rapped to that topic up by saying
fair enough let's move on and I was
attacked because when I said fair enough
it apparently suggested I agreed with
the position or that I was coddling the
view very similarly you and you
interviewed David Duke at a certain
point you could sort of concede that
you're not going to agree and you're
going to move on and the New York Times
picked up on a completely out of context
soundbite to imply that you were in some
way agreeing with the guy yeah it was
actually slightly worse than that okay
it was at the end of an hour-long
interview where I yelled at him
sometimes at the top of my luck's yes
hey and called him an anti-semite a
bigot a racist etc and at the end of the
interview he says now Jake you know I'm
not a racist and which is the most
hilarious thing anyone's ever said from
a former Grand Wizard of the Ku Klux
Klan and a guy who just for an hour
straight talk about how racist he was
and I sarcastically go no of course not
and the New York Times took that and
printed it as if I was
agreeing with David Duke and I told him
that he was not anti-semitic or racist
right and so that and I told her
reporter I talked to her and I said you
just watched the interview it's okay if
you watch the interview you'll give a
proper context you know you don't have
to agree with me on anything all you
gotta do is watch the interview she said
oh no I'm definitely watch the interview
we send it to her right after they are
call and she wrote it as if I agreed
with his anti-semitism that's why I say
I was stunned that it wasn't just
negligence that appeared to be malicious
like purposely trying to smear you now
the thing I'm because we I know that you
do that all the time you have these
extremists on and you battle them now
there's this ideology that no you should
never have that side on we should just
try to do a media blackout of them but
no it's super important so when I had
David Duke on I actually learned
something really important I think our
audience learned something important
from that unfortunately it proved to be
very appreciative was going to come on
in 2015 backing Donald Trump mainly
talking about Latinos and Muslims
because those were the two campaign
themes Muslim travel ban build a wall
etc but he hardly mentioned Latinos or
Muslims at all and then I thought okay
well it's Grand Wizard Klan black people
no he barely mentioned them no he was
obsessed with the Jews Jews run the
world that's why you see in this short
clip we have online where I'm he names a
Jewish banker I name a non Jewish banker
the Jewish person the media I name 8
non-jewish people in the media B to
debunk his conspiracy theory but the
important lesson from that was oh my god
they're gonna come for the Jews and then
what happened Trump gets into office
synagogues shooting after synagogue
shooting and Charlottesville and they
have they chant the Jews will not
replace us because when I found out in
that interview is despite all their
racism and bigotry and in spite away
this is backed up by the national stats
I'm still the number one hate crime is
against Jews in America because in their
crazy right-wing conspiracy theories
when you go all the way down the rabbit
hole it's that the Jews Iran the world
and they're the number one
enemy and if you don't talk to them
you're not gonna find that out no
question about it let we're gonna go to
a break on the broadcast show but
continue our conversation with jenk on
the youtube channel so I understand that
corporate media often has a bias number
one to the status quo and number two to
salaciousness so even reporters who
can't pronounce your name if their life
depended on it are sure that they need
to talk about all of the bad things that
you've done and said etc I understand
that piece you the part that to me is
getting a little concerning is that even
like personal friends I know on my
Facebook page are tweeting stuff
having no idea who you are about how
you'd better not support this guy and
this person and that person had better
retract their endorsement and it's
starting to me to seem like one of these
sort of circular firing squad
self-destructive things I mean make it
about policy and I've not seen anybody
say hey you know what Jenks wrong on
this policy and I love the policy of
Jenks opponent I'm seeing none of that
I'm seeing the types of attacks that to
me are completely self-destructive so
David that's the third group so there's
the Democrats disingenuous there's a
corporate media that turns out to be
even more hostile to progresses and we
realize then the third group is I think
honest actors who we agree with on the
policy but we now disagree on a really
interesting issue / tactic yes yes so
when you and I battle right wingers some
portion of those folks who are genuine
progressives don't like that and there's
this thing called cancel culture so and
it's a legitimate and interesting debate
to have you and I happen to fall on the
side of no if you ignore them they don't
go away they fester right and by the way
David you were doing this more than
anyone else you and Sam cedar are
probably the top at it and and for a
while we actually tried that Anna and I
stopped talking about the right-wing at
all we stopped talking about Dave Rubin
and Ben Shapiro and Milo and all those
guys and we hope
they would go away they didn't go away
that tactic totally did not work now you
could say hey I don't care that it
doesn't work I just don't want those
monsters to get one second extra of
airtime even if you're battling them we
happen to disagree on that but that
doesn't make us bad people and that
doesn't make the opposite side bad
people either meaning the progressives
who are in that cancer culture and not
deep platforming etc but it's a real
intellectual disagreement and any but if
they take it further than they go well
Jane cougar or David Pakman are bad
people that are not really progressives
because they platform people well then I
would say okay you cross the line will
you cross the line from an interesting
intellectual conversation or debate into
being unfortunately malicious that's we
I'm not doing that to them as you could
tell here right I'm saying I hear you
brothers and sisters but let's talk it
out when you think about the path
forward for the campaign you've got the
stuff from the blog posts and the
corporate media reaction to that you've
got some of these folks that you agree
with on policy but seem to disagree on
tactics
you've got arguments like Genk doesn't
live in the district
therefore dot dot dot you know fill in
the blanks what's the strategy for
dealing with this because you actually
since it's gotten national attention you
may need one strategy nationally but
then also something different when
you're talking to the voters in the
district yeah absolutely so first of all
as part of the national conversation and
your viewers are obviously all over the
country
look it's there's two things that are
happening now the corporate media is
overwhelmingly against me every article
is against me they make it seem like my
entire history is being some sort of
right-wing misogynist and they all know
that's not true they they all know that
they critiqued me before for being too
progressive it's so disingenuous
so that's millions of dollars in free
media to smear me plus all the
corporations I criticize are now pouring
in money to my opponent plus all the
Democratic Party they're like oh no he's
gonna call out the corruption pouring in
millions to my opponent so J 2020 com
it's so important
we fight back and if you guys help out
we can fight back on every level here so
nationally I'm saying for God's sake is
any reporter ever going to ask about the
issues I was on the phone with an LA
Times reporter and I literally asked him
connect but this is my second time
talking to you there was an initial
article then there was this and I said
are you ever going to ask about the
issues and he was honest enough to say
no he said we did two to three articles
on a race like this and this is gonna be
the second one and now I'm not gonna ask
you about the issues in this interview
okay well he didn't write that in the
story but at least he told me and at
least there's a modicum of honesty there
I just do sensationalism I don't care
about the issues but the thing is for
people's lives in in the district what I
wrote 19 years ago is the least relevant
thing on planet earth whether they're
gonna have health care is the most
relevant thing there is there's gonna be
school shootings when kids go to those
schools is the most relevant thing on
earth and also there are so many
important local issues there's like
environmental disasters all over the
district there's so many fires the
biggest gas leak in American history
it was Aliso Canyon gas leak that's in
our district we have a Boeing facility
that's leaking radioactive material into
the water and then you've got
homelessness running amuck in Lancaster
and Palmdale so these are super
important issues and it's amazing how
little the press cares about yeah well
that's what my focus you know nobody
really needs to adjudicate whether they
like or don't like you the fact that you
raided women in the past or whatever the
case is because the question is not
about whether any kind of crime was
committed nobody has asserted that this
is not an issue what we're talking about
is does that mean you put someone in
whose health care policy won't actually
get health care to everybody who needs
it or does that do we because of these
things that Genk said which he has
already talked about and and completely
disavowed do we say let's put in someone
that is going to do nothing about
campaign finance reform for example and
that
why I think the lack of discussion about
issues is so acutely disturbing because
what's implied in that is that they
essentially don't matter it's basically
assessing someone's character on the
basis of old blog post that's how we
pick people to represent this now that's
scary to me yeah on as far as my
opponents concern I totally understand
her strategy because Democratic voters
agree with me almost universally and
they don't agree with her positions so
I'm for medicare-for-all
81% of Democratic voters want a
medicare-for-all now why would she be so
bad at politics to be against 81% voters
well it's because of the donors her
donors told her I don't care if you lose
this race but under no circumstances are
you allowed to be for Medicare for all
and it's not just her donors it's the
donors of the Democratic Party that's
why the orders come from down top from
the top down all the way to Christie say
no the party is against Matt you're all
in fact Joe Biden said in the other day
he said the party is not there yet not
that the voters aren't there you have
the party's not there yet so Democratic
Party's decided we're gonna try to synch
Medicare for all it's definitely because
of their corruption I'm super clear on
that and that's why they can't stand me
that's why they're trying to bury me but
at least I understand what Chrissy's
trying to avoid the issues because the
issues are terrible for her the media on
the other hand they are so they pride
themselves on being cynical I got I know
that I see nothing in life matters
thank God why are you a reporter think
nothing matters then why do you cover
the news what if strange toxic culture
there is in the mainstream press don't
talk about the issues only do character
assassinations and personal attacks and
things that are scandalous or salacious
because no one cares make some money
yeah two quick things and I know you've
got a run one is California is a jungle
primary meaning everybody is sort of
running against each other in the
primary Republicans and Democrats
and one of the people running on the
Republican side is George papadopolis
who is this Trump associate who was
indicted it does does he throw a wrench
into what you're doing at all or is it
just talk about your your issues and
just go forward and do your thing
no first of all he doesn't exist so I've
got of these campaign events I've never
seen Papadopoulos I don't know that he's
ever ever been in the district right now
all over the district I'm knocking on
doors they see me at their door me like
you're running for Congress and you're
at my door like because I'm going to
areas of lancaster palmdale that are
heavily Latino or african-american
they've never had anyone come knock on
their door and ask them what would you
like my job is to represent okay so but
Papadopoulos is nowhere to be found but
to be fair he might be in the witness
protection program which make it hard to
win yeah
and so you platforming or not I'm told
all of my opponents and there's actually
13 people in the race debate anytime
anywhere okay
so corporate Democrat you think I'm a
monster you think you have all this dirt
on me by the way quick aside there the
last tweets you put out was like another
damning video it was me arguing for the
two-state solution mm-hmm and then even
some of our own supporters were like
wait are you against the two-state
solution why is that damning great so my
point is she doesn't want it to be
because she actually wants to avoid
every single issue there is the
Republicans are running for me I'm right
here I'm right here come at me bro and
guys like Papadopoulos who couldn't
possibly hang in a debate with me so as
far as you know the the the endorsements
which you've said you're not accepting
endorsements the way this entire thing
has gone do you feel betrayed by some
people that you thought were in your
corner and and at least publicly now
can't be I mean I can imagine that that
doesn't feel particularly good yeah
actually I swear to God I don't feel
that at all and because they give you a
little internal dynamics here
the folks who endorsed me were wonderful
and courageous and and I actually deeply
deeply appreciate it and the last thing
I want to do is get them in trouble and
the press loves smear by proxy okay so
no I I don't feel bad about that at all
they some folks who never even went in
that direction that's a slightly
different story okay okay so so
understand that don't get upset at
Bernie and Roe and Nina they were
wonderful wonderful they were the first
to come out and they took tremendous
courage to back me knowing how the smear
machine has come after me over and over
again they knew that and they still took
that risk so I give them all the credit
in the world but really David there's
like one day I'll tell the stories but
there's groups that are unfortunately
disingenuous and and did a lot of
backroom machinations against me it's
not at all their membership in those
groups the membership is awesome but
some of the leadership is in bed with
the corporate Democrats and they think
oh I'm gonna get 7% more if I work with
Pelosi and Feinstein to help their
hand-picked candidate so let's purposely
maliciously try to bury the progressive
while pretending to be either a
progressive group a somewhat progressive
group etc and so some of that happened
and so there are a couple of names I
wrote down on a list someday maybe we
will we will get get a look at that list
an incredible race in California is 25th
in that it is really a case study
actually in a lot of the sort of worst
of status-quo
politics which we're obviously going to
keep following we've been speaking with
Genki auger who is running to represent
California's 25th district in Washington
DC
Genk always so good to talk to you
really appreciate your time thank you
David please everybody
2020 calm and even if you don't want to
donate you can volunteer you make
from anywhere this is people power
versus corporate power the battles in
the 25th
Jeng 2020 calm thank you guys